MARIANNE SLIGHT: Welcome
to our session today,
accelerating insights with
the health analytics platform.
I'm Marianne Slight, a product
manager on the health care
team of Google Cloud.
And with me is my
colleague, Vivian Neilley,
who leads the health
care customer engineering
specialists.
We're going to talk
today about clinical data
and the challenges facing
health systems as they deal
with a proliferation
of the HR instances
and ancillary clinical systems.
So how do you get your data
into the new standard spire
or into the OMOP
common data model?
How do you align your
different modalities
of data, your different
terminologies of data?
How do you create and
manage the pipelines
to handle that data
transformation?
How do you abstract
out structured data
from the unstructured
clinical mode?
And then how do you analyze
this data in a coherent fashion
without needing
advanced SQL skills?
These are the
challenges that we're
going to talk about
within this presentation.
So let's start off by talking
about data harmonization--
how you harmonize all of your
different siloed data sources
into something that's coherent
and ready for analysis.
And typically, you might
have several different EHR
instances, each of which
is configured differently
from the next.
Or perhaps you've
acquired hospitals,
and they use a different
EHR system than you did.
As well as the EHR
data sources, you also
have clinical ancillary systems
like lab systems or pharmacy
systems.
And all of this data harmonized
into something coherent
enables you to
analyze more richly
your clinical environment.
But it's not just current
data that's important.
You also need to add
on the historical data.
And so what we typically see
are historical data sources
that come to Google Cloud in the
form of CSV files or databases
with incremental or
streaming data coming in
through HR7 version 2 or
using the new FHIR standard.
And that's dealing
with the data sources.
What you harmonize to is
over on the right hand side--
some kind target schema.
And that might be something
like the FHIR schema,
or it might be something
like the OMOP observation
or common data model that
is used for analyzing data
for research purposes.
But most commonly,
it's some combination
of a standard schema and
then custom extensions
in order to support any
investments you've already
made for applications
that sit on top of it.
And so supporting
custom schemas is also
part of our data
harmonization suite.
Now, in order to go
from your data sources
into your target
schema, you typically
need to have your data undergo
four types of transformation.
The first of these is field
mappings, where perhaps you're
taking patient_ID in
this database over here,
you've got MRN, or
medical record number,
as the name of the field
over in this data source,
and perhaps you've also got
member ID in another data
source, and you're
trying to harmonize it
into, say, the FHIR schema
with the patient resource
and the identifier attribute.
That's field mappings.
Terminology mappings
looks at how
you label the clinical
concepts within your data.
So perhaps you're
capturing your medications
using first databank in this
EHR, but over in Sterner,
you're capturing them using
the [? Moulton ?] medical
terminology.
And perhaps you want to
harmonize those into RX norm.
These are three different
clinical terminologies
that are used for
medications, and you
need to be able to
harmonize the concepts
into a coherent single
clinical terminology for each
of your different concept types.
Units alignment is another
step within data harmonization
because different lab systems
produce the lab test results
with different units.
Often that's just by
a factor of 1,000,
but sometimes it's a little
more broader than that.
As when a particular lab test,
its standard unit of measure
changes at a particular
point in time.
And in that case,
the system needs
to understand the point
at which the units changed
from one to another in
order that you can end up
with harmonized data
in consistent units
in your analytic target.
And finally, abstracting
out structured data
from the unstructured
clinical note.
And I'll talk more
about that in a moment.
So we recently launched our
mapping configuration language,
which we call Whistle
And we've launched
this to open source so that
the entire community can
benefit from this.
What the Whistle mapping
configuration language does
is it enables you to convert
from an input in JSON format
into an output in JSON
format using a mapping
configuration that you've
written using Whistle.
And what's unique
about Whistle is
that it supports repeated
and nested structures, which,
of course, are so critical
within support for HR 7
version 2 and within support
for the FHIR standard.
It also supports calls for
terminology maps, calls
for unit harmonization, and
for clinical entity extraction
using natural
language processing.
And you can create your own
user defined functions, as well.
Now, here's an example of
how you might convert an HR 7
message that
incorporates the name
and address of a particular
health system into FHIR.
And the gray box at
the bottom, that's
an example of the
Whistle mapping
configuration that you
would create to do that.
When we launched our Whistle
data transformation language
within our open source
GitHub repository,
we also launched sample
maps to get you started.
We included sample maps for two
different message types of HR 7
version 2 map to FHIR, and
we also included sample maps
for mapping from FHIR to OMOP.
And these are all available
within our GitHub repo.
So you've created this
Whistle mapping configuration.
Now how do you run it?
We have three
different ways that you
can run a Whistle
mapping configuration,
create a pipeline,
and convert your data.
The first is using the
Google Cloud health care API.
So if you're importing your
data from cloud storage
into the FHIR API, or if
you're exporting your data
from the FHIR API into
BigQuery, or if you're
moving your data from
the HR 7 version 2
store into the FHIR
store on Google Cloud,
in each of these cases you can
incorporate a Whistle mapping
configuration to transform the
data as you move it across.
The second way is using
Cloud Data Fusion,
which is a Google tool that is
a fully managed service for ETL
pipelines.
And what that allows
you to do is have access
to a library of different
pre-configured sources,
and connectors, and
transformations,
and a library of reconfigured
outputs or sinks, as well.
And what's really unique
about Cloud Data Fusion
is that this is a fully
managed environment
that does it by drag and
drop using a graphical UI.
And that helps you to
get away from managing
all of your pipelines
with code into focusing
on the actual transformations
that are getting done
and moving you away
towards insight and action.
The third way is an open
sourced cloud data flow
pipeline that we launched
earlier that converts--
this reference pipeline
converts streaming HR 7 version
2 messages into FHIR resources.
And so that, too, is
available on our GitHub repo.
Now, I want to talk
about clinical notes
briefly in a bit more detail.
This is an example
of an ICU note.
It's very dense.
This is just a
very small section
of what's typically
reams of paper
if you were to print it all out.
It's reams of paper
because a lot of it
is copied from one
node to another.
It's copied forward.
But the other issue with
these kinds of notes
is it's difficult to find the
real wealth of information
that's buried in
this density of text.
And it's dense because there's
a lot of different types
of abbreviation.
It's also dense with a lot
of different weirdities
or oddities in punctuation,
because some of this note
is actually
generated by the EHR.
And then it's not
just speaking English,
it's also speaking
Latin, as well.
And what's challenging
about the clinical note
is when you look at it, each
of these different roles
might see something different.
So when a physician looks
at that note and says, well,
does this patient have sepsis?
They will be looking at it
from a different perspective
than the medical coder,
than the CDI nurse,
than the clinical
quality analyst.
The physician is typically
looking at it to say,
could this patient
possibly have sepsis?
Because if so, he or she
is going to do something
different as a
result. They're going
to follow a different
care pathway.
Whereas the medical coder is
looking at the note to say,
does this note justify
a diagnosis of sepsis?
Because if so, that will
result in a different code
on the medical claim.
They undergo different training,
and these different roles
are looking at it one from
the perspective of discovery,
the other from the
perspective of compliance.
So there are different models
for these different use cases,
and clearly one size
does not fit all.
And so what we are looking at
in terms of clinical entity
extraction are these four areas.
The first is abstracting
the actual clinical concepts
themselves-- the diagnoses, the
medications, the procedures,
the observations, and so on.
The second is looking at the
relations and the attributes
about those key
clinical entities.
So for example, with
medications, what was the dose?
What was the route?
When was it ordered?
Functional features talks
about the semantic context
of the clinical entities.
So was that diagnosis actually
positive for the patient,
or was it documented as
a rule out diagnosis?
Did this other diagnosis
impact the patient,
or instead did it pertain
to the patient's parent,
and actually it should be part
of family and medical history?
Terminology mappings, because
when you abstract out this data
it needs to be coded into one
of those clinical terminologies
that the rest of the
structured data described as.
I said that one model
doesn't fit all,
and so we also enable tuning
of these clinical entity
extraction models using AutoML.
And AutoML allows you to
augment or enrich a model
with a sample of your
own data that you
have labeled for your unique
documentation practices.
Or perhaps you have
unique abbreviations.
Perhaps you've got specific use
cases that you need to support,
and AutoML allows you
to tune that model
for your specific circumstance.
So you've harmonized your data
using our data harmonization
tools into something coherent.
Now how do you analyze it?
Leveraging BigQuery enables us
to provide scalable analytics.
It's analytic database, because
it's structured as a columnar
database, and it's
scalable because it scales
through petabytes horizontally.
All of the data is encrypted
both at rest and in motion
by default, and the data
is accessible using SQL.
So all of those business
intelligence tools over
on the right hand side
can access the data
within BigQuery using
their native capabilities.
We also have a number of public
data sets available on BigQuery
for you to integrate into
your analysis, as well.
And we recently launched
the OMOP common data model
as an open source GitHub
repo on top of BigQuery.
And further, the ATLAS
cohort definition tool
on top of Cloud Marketplace
in Google Cloud.
And what that
allows you to do is
to use the OMOP
common data model
and analyze the data
on BigQuery directly.
So understanding
the terminologies,
the vocabularies, looking at
database-level statistics,
understanding your
patient profiles,
and looking at your
cohort definitions
using the ATLAS tool all
directly on top of BigQuery.
This is an example of
the ATLAS cohort manager
tool looking at the prevalence
of medications in this data set
and understanding the
different medications
and their prevalence.
I said we had a number of
public data sets available.
This is a subset of the
health care data sets
that are available on BigQuery.
The first two are large
synthetic data sets
in two different
forms to allow you
to experiment with these
different types of data.
The first is FHIR using the
synthetic data from MITRE,
and then second is [? Synpath ?]
using synthetic data
in the OMOP common data model.
But as well as those
two synthetic data sets,
we have a large number of
curated current data sets.
Most recently we
have added data sets
in the fields of social
determinants of health,
and these are kept
current every quarter
and take social determinant data
such as incope data, snap data,
homelessness down to, in
many cases, the county level
so that you can match this data
with your own health system
data in order to understand the
impact of social determinants
on your particular population.
We also added the COVID-19 case
data from the New York Times,
and then there are a
number of other data sets--
health care data sets--
that are available
and kept current.
And we're adding
more all the time.
Finally, how do
you analyze data?
You analyze data
using dashboards often
in order to generate action.
So what are the
decisions that you
want to make on the
basis of that analysis?
Well dashboards, and in
particular our Looker offering,
enables you to look at
key performance indicators
from your health system.
In this example, I'm looking at
readmission rates, mortality,
and average length of stay
across my entire hospital
system.
Obviously, I can look
at that over time.
I can drill into
specific facilities.
Over on the right
hand side, you can
see that I'm looking at
some of the key diagnoses
and procedures those
costly, chronic, often
comorbid conditions,
and looking at where
I have a potential to
improve those key performance
indicators.
And I can drill into
that in more detail.
And if I drill
into, for example,
AMI, then I can see for
my AMI patients, those
on the right hand side who are
most at risk of bouncing back
with a readmission.
And that risk score has been
generated using a machine
learning model directly within
BigQuery using a BQML model
that takes advantage of some
of the public data sets that we
looked at earlier-- some of the
social determinant data sets--
but also takes
into account things
like the number of comorbidities
and the discharge date
relative to now, as well
as the age of the patient.
And so finally, these are
some of the demonstration
of the correlations
between the risk score
and some of the social
determinant data.
In these examples, household
data and SNAP enrollment data.
So we've talked about the
capabilities of the health care
analytics platform.
Let's talk about one
specific use case, and that's
a clinical data cloud for FHIR.
Because increasingly,
we're seeing
FHIR in use in health systems
as its central real time
repository for
clinical data because
of its longitudinal
patient records support.
And so in this example here,
you harmonize your data
into FHIR using the
tools that we've talked
about for data harmonization.
You make the data available
in analytics on BigQuery,
you store the data natively
in the health care FHIR store
as part of the health care API.
All of this sits on top of the
data protection suite, which
encompass our support
for HIPAA best practices,
and we also enable
access to that data
through the FHIR application
layer that includes
SMART on FHIR and also Apigee.
And now I'm going to hand
it over to my colleague,
Vivian Neilley, who's going to
talk about the architecture.
VIVIAN NEILLEY:
Thank you, Marianne.
So when we think through how
data flows through this system,
there are five conceptual steps
it takes to get to a place
where users can of service it
to applications or to perhaps
to other analytics use cases.
As Marianne discussed, there are
a vast amount of data sources
that can be ingested.
From EHR data, to
patient generated
data, even with imaging data.
All of these different
source systems
result in different
products being
utilized for data ingestion.
Our health care
API, for example,
takes three different
modalities, FHIR, DICOM,
and HL7.
While something like our cloud
storage or blob storage product
can handle a wide
variety of data
that may be coming from
data warehouses, or patient,
or other data sources truly,
the data harmonization layer
is really where
the magic happens.
All the aspects of harmonization
are handled in this step,
including utilizing the
Whistle transformation language
in order to get your
data to a common data
model it can persist in.
While this
architecture highlights
utilizing Cloud Data
Fusion for harmonization,
as Marianne discussed, users can
also leverage our Google Cloud
health care API or Cloud
Dataflow as the infrastructure
to do these transformations.
Once it's in a persistent layer,
whether that be in the health
care API under FHIR or
perhaps in BigQuery,
we really moved to
the enrichment stage.
And this is where users
get to explore their data
and drive insights
from their data.
So users can connect with a
plethora of other Google Cloud
products such as our AI
platforms or AI platform
notebooks, which is really just
a managed Jupyter notebook.
We even allow for
applications that
are hosted on our
marketplace for VM images
to be able to use some of the
other applications that'll
be publishing by
other institutions
within your data set.
The second architecture
that I go over
is really more of a
technical architecture
of the flow of the data.
As I discussed, the various
different source systems
result in various different
ingestion processes.
So while batch data
or historical data
might come in on Cloud
Storage, real time data
comes in usually within HL7
v2 or perhaps device data.
That's going to be handled
on a transactional database
and may land in the health
care API store or one
of our other application-based
products such as our app
engine.
The transformation
and harmonization step
here is happening with
Cloud Data Fusion,
and mean there is the
various different ways
that data can be handled.
Metadata can appear one
way, and other data,
such as your analytics
data, your deidentify data,
can be surfaced through BigQuery
and utilized with products
such as our private catalog.
I'm now going to show you a demo
of the solution we discussed.
So now we're going to be
demonstrating that end
to end architecture that
we just talked through.
From an input, in this case and
HL7 message, to transformation,
storing it in a FHIR store,
and exporting it to BigQuery.
What's going to be
sending our HL7 messages
is a tool called
simulated hospital.
Google has open
sourced this tool,
and essentially what it does
is it sends synthetic HL7
messages to whatever application
you're looking to test.
It allows you to choose
how many pathways per hour.
For this case, I'm going to turn
it all the way up for the demo.
This source code can be
found google.com/simhospital.
We're going to hop
to the pipeline.
This pipeline has been
built in Data Fusion.
Data Fusion is
great for users who
are more familiar with
UI-based pipeline building.
It's running on top of Dataproc,
or really our managed Hadoop
product.
You can see here we have
plugins, and inputs,
and outputs for each of
the step of the pipeline.
Our HL7 store Pub/Sub,
if we'd look into this,
we can figure out
which subscription
we are listening to,
what the naming is,
and truly where
it's coming from.
We're currently at
200 HL7 messages.
I-- nope, I'm about hop to 201.
So as we're going
through the demo,
you can see and fundamentally
watch each of the messages
go through the steps
and how long it
takes for them to
get to the FHIR store
and be able to write.
These mapping boxes are
calling our Whistle code.
What Whistle is is we have
open sourced a configuration
language that allows for
arbitrary JSON to arbitrary
JSON.
We have also open sourced
reference mappings for HL7
to FHIR, and we are utilizing
those reference mappings
during this demonstration.
So what that means is you can
pull both this pipeline as well
as our reference mappings to
be able to automatically spin
up or quickly spin up
a HL7 to FHIR pipeline
in your environment.
We've stored those on a GCS
bucket you can see here.
And over in the properties
for the FHIR store,
it will tell you where
the FHIR store is located,
the data set name,
and FHIR store ID.
We can also look at the
documentation and the metrics
to see how frequently
data is writing
to the FHIR store
in this pipeline.
So if we hop over and we want
to look a little bit more
into this mapping
Whistle configuration.
First, though, I'm going
to go into BigQuery.
This is where the final
data is being written.
So from the FHIR store,
it is being exported
and streamed into BigQuery.
It is falling into
this FHIR data set.
You can see each
of the resources
creates a table within BigQuery.
So just to test that we
are, indeed, sending data,
I'm going to run a count of
the number of observations
in my data set.
We're currently at 18,912.
So I'm going to hop over to our
Jupyter notebook demonstration
and go back to
this just to prove
my honesty of the
streaming real time
capabilities of the pipeline.
So here in Jupyter
Notebooks, we have also
open sourced fundamentally
a UI for users
to be able to understand,
evaluate, and reference
against their Whistle code.
Also does some FHIR
validation that I'll
walk through, as well.
For the input, since Whistle is
an arbitrary JSON to arbitrary
JSON logic, the HL7 messages
that are traditionally
hex-based messages go
through our HL7 parser
to then be transformed
into a JSON object.
So I'm going to be loading that
JSON object from Google Cloud
Storage into our notebook here.
We can look at this.
This is an ADT message.
The MSH header is
here, and this is
how the passing logic
treats the message in each
of the segments.
So now we're going to actually
go transform that message.
This particular magic command
lets users execute the scripts.
You can display it in real time.
You can then use it to go
store as another variable.
It will show you
what the FHIR bundle
looks like at the end
of your Whistle code.
So we're going to be
processing the ADT.
We've defined that in previous--
in the open source code
that'll show in a minute.
I'll go ahead and run this.
So you can see it's creating
a transactional bundle
with several different entries.
This particular
one is requesting,
so it's going to be--
the request method is a
put to the FHIR store,
and it's putting
an organization ID.
Each of these functions
that I'm calling
are stored in various different
areas of the open source code.
So messages, for
example, we can see
here's the code
that's defining how
to transform your ADT message.
We also have the
segments Whistle.
So this is the code that was
defining that MSH header.
All this, again, is
available open source
on our git repository.
So we can go back here and
now test out whether or not
that FHIR resource
we just created
is actually going to be written
and valid for the FHIR store.
So we're going to
transform another message.
And then we're going to
check its validation.
So this is an invalid
FHIR resource.
I actually did that
on purpose just
to demonstrate the ability
for us to on the fly
make changes that then can be
affecting of the validation.
So hopefully when
we try this again,
you can see here it is,
indeed, a valid source.
So now it's going to be
writing to the FHIR store.
And everything that we do on
this Jupyter notebook actually
changes the Google Cloud
Storage and the Whistle code
you're utilizing.
So this can be a
very valuable tool
for folks who are more
familiar with the notebook-like
interface.
Again, all of this is open
sourced at Google Cloud
Platform's git auditory at
healthcare-dataharmonization.
So now if we hop back
into BigQuery, let's
run this command again.
Great, it went up.
And so you can see the
streaming results of this
is in real time on
how many observations
it is actually writing
into the BigQuery data set.
Now for FHIR, for
those who are familiar,
it can be a pretty
complicated data format
and data standard to utilize.
So a little bit more complicated
of a query can be found here.
Essentially what I'm
going to be doing
is pulling some patients
from the patient resource.
Since the patient,
or all resources,
are nested and have
arrays in them,
you have to use the safe
offset command within BigQuery.
That allows you to see a flat
view of patient IDs, phones,
birthdays, addresses,
things like this.
Now, for those who don't want to
write such a complicated query
against BigQuery, or maybe are
just not as familiar with SQL,
we had a recent
acquisition, Looker,
who the semantic
layer within Looker
actually can understand
the FHIR data standard
and write the queries for you.
So it can take that complicated
nests and arrays within,
unnest it on the fly, and
create beautiful visualizations
for this complicated data model.
Here we have an example
of a patient that
is utilizing Looker,
and their data
is stored in the
FHIR data standard.
So you can see they're
from Massachusetts.
80 years old.
This is an encounter timeline.
The larger a diamond is, the
longer the encounter was.
And you can kind of see
their vitals over time.
This can be effective
patient management
for doctors or clinicians
to be able to understand
what their patient looks like
across the continuum of care.
We then can also go over to
more of an administrative view,
which is allowing for us to
visualize how many patients
is going through
a system, what's
the average length of
stay or readmission rate,
as well as an overview
of your population.
For any of these
particular statistics,
we actually have the
ability to drill into them.
So I have the ability
to drill into and see
each of the patients that
are making up that statistic.
If I'm interested in
this particular patient,
I have the ability to
follow up with him,
or see his overview which is
that very similar dashboard
to the last one we
were seeing for each
of the individual patients.
Looker going to be a
great tool to abstract
that complicated data
model into a layer
that you are able to
drive meaning from,
gain insights from, as well as
even do some machine learning
modeling here.
Thank you so much for coming.
For more information, check out
our harmonization GitHub repo
and contact your sales
rep on how to get started.